sri lanka's energy minister says the
country has no money left to pay for
fuel imports and that essentially means
sri lankans queuing for petrol at gas
stations will get nothing the small fuel
reserve the country does have will only
be released for essential services like
ambulances
as the economic crisis worsens so does
the political one on tuesday parliament
voted against an opposition motion to
condemn president gutaba raj baksha for
his handling of the crisis
protesters have been calling for his
resignation for months but he continues
to remain unmoved
new prime minister ranil vikrama singh
has warned the country has to face court
unpleasant and terrifying facts in many
ways sri lankans are already facing them
but that's only increased their
determination for change
it's been weeks
and the people of sri lanka are still on
the streets
praising slogans and singing songs of
hope
they demand a better future and a
complete political overhaul in their
country
a familiar face as the new premier has
done nothing to assuage them
ranal vikrama singha a seasoned
politician has been appointed as the
prime minister of sri lanka he has held
the post five times previously but never
completed the full term
while some people find hope in him many
others have their own doubts
many distrust vikrama sinha
they see him as being close to the
ruling rajapaksa family who they want
gone from power
we don't have any faith in the current
prime minister to be honest like no one
has faith in him given his history and
like given the fact that he is
basically got a reputation for being
incredibly wishy washy and inept
they want to hide their corruption that
is why they have brought in rik
ramasinghi as the prime minister
as the prime minister most recently he
is remembered for shielding
the rajapaksas when he was prime
minister in the previous government even
as cynicism abounds about his
appointment
the new prime minister has his task cut
out for him
needless to say vikrama singha faces an
uphill battle of pulling an essentially
bankrupt country out of its grave crisis
he has called on all the political
parties of the country to leave their
political differences behind and help
him rebuild the economy
that is likely a tall order
iran vikramaratnee is a member of the
main opposition party
he says his party is ready to support
but only under certain conditions
even though we have disagreed with the
appointment of the present prime
minister because he does not have
an independent majority in parliament we
are still willing to work with it and we
will be in opposition and will cooperate
but
if they try to play hard politics and if
they approach members from our party and
go that road then certainly we will not
be cooperating with this government but
no one has come up with solutions for
the crisis
and the situation is likely to get worse
for sri lankans in the coming months
vikrama singha has warned they would be
the most difficult ones of their lives
and joining me now for more from colombo
is dr pakistan
he's executive director of the center
for policy alternatives doctor several
number two welcome how confident are
people in sri lanka that the new prime
minister ranil vikrama singh is the man
to lead them out of this crisis
i think their opinion is divided there
are people who dislike credibly criminal
singer who they feel has always
protected the rajapakses
and that he has not been
a very honest leader etc then there are
those who feel that despite all of that
he is a technocrat at one level and that
he has good contacts internationally and
that he will get the economy back on its
feet and that there are those who agree
with that and sort of say look he is the
man of the ah he's the only one who can
succeed but in reality i suppose we have
a crisis of governance there is an
economic side and a political side and
you have to
address
both those issues in
coordination with each other working on
the economic issue however
strong it is
is not in itself going to
get the protesters to go away or
anything like that
i'd like to just go back to the first
point that you made about people who
believe that maybe he is
protecting the rajapaksha family i mean
so far four cabinet appointments have
been made all of them from uh president
raja paksha's political party i'm
wondering does that further lend
substance to that view that one vikrama
singh is indeed the rajapaksa's man
well i mean he is the only member of his
party in parliament they didn't win a
single seat in the last election and
what he is in parliament on is a bonus
seat so in that respect yes he would be
seen as uh you know giving the raj boxes
a lease of life in that he did not make
any conditions for taking the job on he
said that the economy is in dire straits
and that ostensibly was the reason why
he was accepting the prime ministership
however once he's come into office
he has
said that the 21st amendment will be
looked at and it's been sent to
the attorney general's department and it
will come to cabinet so there is some
movement on the political front but the
question is is it enough
and is it going to last for long enough
to get the economy also on a sound
footing
let's just talk about uh president
gutaba raja paksha i mean he has also
talked about reform along with
ronald vikram asinga and
president raja paksha has talked about
divesting himself of all of these
all-encompassing powers he accumulated
two years back but nothing really has uh
happened on that front uh and people are
also asking for him to resign
can you help us understand the thinking
behind all of this i mean the whole
country wants reform and for president
raja paksha to go but he isn't complying
why is that
i think
gotab rajpuksa is not resigning despite
the public clamor for his resignation
because he's not just president on his
own
he represents an entire family a dynasty
who are accused at one level of war
crimes and crimes against humanity and
at another level of having robbed left
right and center
and so if he goes he will lose whatever
immunity he gets from prosecution he and
the rest of his family will be very
vulnerable to prosecution
to be brought to account and i think
that's the principal reason why he wants
to stay on in power
uh so the people want uh president gotta
by rajpaksha to go and let's assume that
he did
would it make a difference to the
situation in sri lanka i mean i only
asked this because sri lanka for
instance wants a bailout from the imf
but having some sort of a stable
government seems to be a prerequisite to
receiving funds
yes under the constitution of the
country if the president resigns the
prime minister becomes president and
within 30 days
parliament should elect someone of its
own a member of parliament to serve out
the unexpired term of the president so i
mean the notion that there might be any
sort of uncertainty and anarchy and all
of that if gotham rajpath resigns is
entirely incorrect there is a process
that has to be followed and it can be
followed now a number of those joining
calls for gotta be raj baksha's ouster
are also former supporters who voted him
into power
i wonder if you think there is a change
that we're witnessing in sri lanka in
terms of what people expect from their
elected representatives
well remember gotham
came into power in 2019 standing on a
platform
of strong decisive leadership
particularly given the background of the
2019 easter bombings as well as the
relative lack of coordination and
incoherence of the previous government
however
his sort of
performance in government has not been
strong or decisive i mean he has only
spoken to the country
once
in this two-month crisis since the
prices came to a head he has flipped and
flopped on a number of decisions and
he's also shown that he doesn't have the
capacity to govern in terms of
understand
economics as one example
okay we'll have to leave it there for
the time being but thank you so much for
joining us today dr [ __ ] sorry
salvation from the center for policy
alternatives thank you sir
thank you